hey this is presh talwalkar
four circles of equal size are inscribed
in a square
inside of the four circles is a smaller
square tangent to each of the four
circles
if the large square has a side length
equal to four
what is the area of the small square
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
the first thing we'll do is we'll
consider the centers of each circle
now we'll solve for the radius of a
single circle
if we extend the radius across two
adjacent circles we'll see that it spans
the side of the large square
the large score side is equal to four
times the length of the radius of a
single circle
and this is equal to four
so we can solve that each circle has a
radius r equals one
now let's form a triangle between the
centers of three circles
this will be an isosceles right triangle
where each leg is equal to two
the hypotenuse of this isosceles right
triangle will be two times the square
root of
you can solve for this by the
pythagorean theorem
but we can also solve for the length of
the hypotenuse by considering the
distances involved
we have one radius length
then we have the length of the small
square which we'll denote by x and then
we have another radius length
so we now have two different ways to
measure the hypotenuse
on the one hand it's equal to two square
root of two and on the other hand it's
equal to 2 plus x where x is the small
square side length
we can therefore solve that x is equal
to 2 square root of 2 minus 2.
this means the area of the small square
is the square of x which equals 12 minus
8 square root of 2 and that's
approximately 0.686
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description